the journey through the panama canal is
expensive
large container ships and tankers pay up
to 1 million us dollars
and this year they've had to carry less
cargo in order to reduce their draft
because the water level has been so low
the canal authority says climate change
is to blame for higher temperatures
and a lack of rainfall the canal passes
through lake gartoon
and is fed by rivers with sources in the
rainforest
we had a very dry 2019
so in february the fresh water rate was
established that's a fixed
10 percent of the amount of the toll and
a variable
depending on the elevation of the lake
every time a ship passes through the
canal 200 million liters of fresh water
are poured into the locks
some of it is recaptured in basins but
most flows into the sea
the freshwater surcharge was introduced
to finance the development of new water
sources
the rivers and lakes that feed the canal
also provide
drinking water for millions of people
securing the supply
depends on the conservation of the rain
forests
but a lot of trees continue to be felt
we are headed to finca cuango the land
was covered in trees until it was turned
into
a cattle ranch a german company one two
tree
that invests in regenerative agriculture
projects
has now bought the finga and is busy
replanting the forest
the estate will focus on the production
of cocoa and native hardwoods
saplings are being planted on the
grassland where cattle used to graze
around 100 people have found work at
cuango
in a region where unemployment is high
because of the pandemic many people lost
their jobs in the city and had to go to
the countryside
i was one of them always learning
something new
on a third of the estate 500 hectares
cocoa will be grown
the project also wants to promote social
progress
in the villages around here a lot of
people are unemployed
and that especially affects us women we
have as good as no job opportunities
because we're women
there isn't much awareness of the issue
of equal opportunities
for now what one sees are lots of banana
trees
the cocoa bushes are still young and
small they grow best in the shade of
banana palms
some are already bearing fruit el
platano
banana plants enhance the soil with a
large amount of organic matter
and the cocoa bushes are expert at
absorbing this organic matter
and using it to grow in production
cultivation we also use pigeon pea
bushes and forest trees
right now mainly almond trees we're
planting around 80 trees per hectare
the banana plants provide shade and for
the time being until more cocoa has
grown
are the main source of income for the
farm
when the coronavirus pandemic hit the
government bought up
almost the entire harvest of cooking
bananas across the country
in order to ensure the supply they are a
staple food here
a strict lockdown meant weekly markets
had to close
700 hectares of the finca are covered in
rainforest
set aside for nature conservation howler
monkeys
insects and amphibians live here
undisturbed
deeper in the forest there are also
pumas anteaters and
ocelots this nature reserve covers
almost half of the estate
and will be left untouched
koango is an integrated agroforestry
project with three main components
the natural rainforest crop farming and
a tree farm
that will provide timber to carpenters
in panama
the trees in the commercial forest are
registered and can only be felt with a
permit
this is what sustainable ecological
investing can
nothing else was being grown to offset
the loss
the fourth and final level is made up of
cedar trees
and above all almond trees which still
have to reach maturity
the owner of cowongo one two tree is
based in berlin
it only engages in green investment it's
also a co-founder of a latin american
climate initiative
petra commands baga the project manager
for central america
can't travel to her office in panama
because of the pandemic they video
conference with roderick bins in cuongo
he says the banana harvest is good and
as to the corona virus
everyone on the estate is healthy again
[Music]
they're busy pressing ahead with the
reforestation effort
a few years ago panama launched the
alliance for one million
initiative which aims to create a
million new hectares of forest
over a period of two decades
the fact that things aren't moving so
fast is largely due to a lack of capital
for investing in new projects like these
at finca cuango they are working to
develop sustainable organic farming
methods that can adapt to the changing
conditions brought about by climate
change
it will take not just encouragement but
also major
investment to win over small holder
farmers to agroforestry
changes to the climate are having a huge
impact on the canal
it can no longer rely on a supply of
water as in previous years
the rains are starting much later in the
season
it's crucial to secure the water supply
and that means more reforestation
projects
panama's economy is dependent on the
canal
restoring forests will enhance the
ecosystem
and yield more fresh water to the
benefit of the people
and the canal
you